another big spectacle coming to town in
10 months time the first ever Las Vegas
Super Bowl and the NFL is looking for a
local minority-owned businesses to help
support it as Ryan Matthey shows us
those businesses pitched to the league
today
guess
the Davila family moved from South
America to Las Vegas nearly two decades
ago if they're from Venezuela right
they're typically be like oh my God this
is just like my grandma makes it
empanadas and all other Venezuelan food
Medallia and her son Miguel make those
here at Rika arepa Express
but they have eyes set on a bigger space
next year for us to be able to be at the
Super Bowl is it just it tells an
immigrant story of Las Vegas that I
don't think gets told a lot in the news
they're one of over 700 businesses
hoping for a spot in the NFL business
connect program it's a list of local
suppliers that the NFL recommends to the
vendors who put on the parties tailgates
and of course the big game itself to
receive that kind of professional
industrial feedback that really helped
them up their game Tuesday applicants
got the chance to pitch their services
to the NFL the league bringing along Las
Vegas industry leaders too David Weimer
and other judges providing feedback to
better appeal to business connect and
even if not chosen he says getting in
front of local leaders will help these
businesses benefit from the
international attention the hope is that
it lives on in this Marketplace so that
these businesses can continue to get
opportunities we have never done a pitch
like this before adjust the experience
of getting in front of judges and
sharing our food is a huge win for us